une véritable bataille navale
interentreprises s'est déroulée ce
samedi 16 et dimanche 17 juin sur l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
la coupe nationale était programmé pour
la dixième fois sur le site
objectif travailler en équipe le
principe de la course ce n'est pas de
gagner la course
c'est d'éviter que son camarade soit
dernier donc c'est applique les
principes à la fois 2
solidarité et de l'application des
règles de course puisque dans ce jeu là
le jeu et règles course est extrêmement
important au total une vingtaine
d'entreprises venus de toute la france
regroupant soixante participants se sont
inscrits toutes ont leur technique pour
dompter les bateaux de 16 pieds
remporter la victoire
déjà bien navigué proprement pas faire
d'erreur et puis surveiller le vent les
êtres premier être devant c'est toujours
indispensable dira le plan d'eau qui est
un peu particulier où donc là il était
situé vent d'ouest donc c'est dans la
relaxe du plan d'eau il faut faire très
attention à la rangée d'arbres qui est
tout au fond sur le plan d'eau est déjà
plein de déventer et petites stratégies
quand même dans l'ensemble comme les
participants auront une nouvelle
occasion de s'illustrer l'année
prochaine une nouvelle édition est déjà
programmée sur le plan d'eau de 200
hectares